this weekend Donald Trump was in Saudi
Arabia it was his first trip overseas as
president he is reportedly already
exhausted making bizarre mistakes after
just a few days there I'll talk about
that a little later in the show while in
Saudi Arabia Donald Trump signed what is
effectively a 10-year 350 billion dollar
weapons deal with the king of Saudi
Arabia
Salman al Salman bin Abdul Aziz this is
the biggest arms deal in American
history and we've known for a while that
the deal was probably going to take
place and this was negotiated by Donald
Trump's son-in-law and advisor Jared
Kushner a leading figure in the Russia
investigation who the White House has
said in the past would be in charge of
Middle East peace as Pat mentioned
earlier in the show the idea of bringing
peace to the Middle East by giving Saudi
Arabia more weapons to use on Yemen is
sort of an interesting contrast well he
also gave a speech to about how he was
going to eliminate terrorism across the
world yes strategy oh it's amazing what
he's doing
White House officials said that this
deal includes Abrams tanks combat ships
missile defense systems radar and
communications and cyber security
technology Saudi Arabia obviously is
expected to use some of these weapons in
their involvement in Yemen's Civil War
against the Houthi armed forces led by
former longtime President Ali Abdullah
Saleh where Saudi Arabia has already
committed war crimes the US has already
been providing Saudi Arabia with
logistical support they're helping them
with intelligence targeting helping them
with drone strikes since the war started
back in 2015 however in October just
before President Obama left office in
response to Saudi Arabia's illegal
bombing of a Yemeni funeral home that
killed hundreds Obama halted the sale of
almost 400 million dollars of weapon
Saudi Arabia this was a small move but
it was a meaningful move Saudi Arabia as
I told you is one of the most oppressive
and vile radical Islamic regimes of the
entire world public beheadings religious
police women's rights
disaster on and on and on I won't redo
the full list right now
so when Obama halted that deal it did
send a message to King Salman and now
Donald Trump is reversing it Trump is
showing his full support effectively of
Saudi Arabia's actions in Yemen and
Saudi Arabia has left Yemen in ruins
they've unlawfully killed thousands and
left them in an almost state of famine
they've destroyed homes they've
destroyed schools markets hospitals
Human Rights Watch has documented
eighty-one illegal attacks in Yemen by
Saudi Arabia in the last two years many
of which were bonafide war crimes and in
many cases American weapons were used to
do the damage so this is yet another
sign that Trump doesn't really care
about the rules of war that's concerning
for the next four years it's yet another
sign that trumps entire muscling
rhetoric is yet again political BS meant
to fire up the right people in the base
because if Trump really cared about
Islamic theocracies doing bad things
your first stop is Saudi Arabia no more
getting medals from Saudi Arabia no more
weapons for Saudi Arabia that we know
will be used to commit war crimes the
Wahhabist theocracy of Saudi Arabia is
at the top of the most extreme Islamic
theocracy a sort of list of concern of
the world and that price tag is also
quite concerning to three hundred and
fifty billion dollars and it's really
not even debated within the mainstream
media I mean at least when Trump
proposes a wall between the u.s. and
Mexico that would come at a cost of 20
to 60 billion dollars we have a debate
about if it's going to be cost-effective
yeah if it's going to solve any problems
out there this is just going to happen
we don't have to talk it over first and
further Trump so fine let's say we just
accept Trump is going to keep helping
Saudi Arabia in Yemen the arms deals are
going to make a ton of money for the
u.s. it's just going to happen can't
Trump do something to discourage the
illegal and devastating attacks that
Saudi Arabia is demolishing Yemen with I
mean put some kind of conditions on the
deal it would be sort of nice if we
could maybe just kind of catch
fear Saudi Arabia away from the war
crimes instead of effectively endorsing
them Trump is saying we have a
bottomless supply of weapons for you
it's there as long as you want it and
you can do whatever you want with it and
by the way most of these weapons some of
these weapons will be made in in Saudi
Arabia so it's not even going to create
American jobs yes it'll be American
contractors that are ultimately getting
the money but Trump talks about creating
American jobs not going to happen
senators Chris Murphy a Democrat and
Rand Paul a Republican have proposed
legislation to limit the amount of arms
that we sell to Saudi Arabia
here is a written statement from Senator
Murphy who said quote I have yet to see
evidence that the Civil War were
supplying and supporting in Yemen
advances our national security the more
it drags on the clearer it becomes that
our military involvement on behalf of
the saudi-led coalition is prolonging
human suffering in Yemen and aiding the
very groups that are intent on attacking
us commenting on Saudi Arabia Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson said earlier this
month quote if we condition too heavily
that others must adopt our values it
really creates obstacles towards our
ability to advance our national security
interests our economic interests
this isn't about values we're talking
about international law the haphazard
killing of people and this idea that hey
hey we've got a tread lightly pat
because we don't want to just impose our
values on to them all of a sudden we
care about imposing our values we don't
care when we bring quote democracy to
other countries in the Middle East with
resources that we want but all of a
sudden hey it's Saudi Arabia we'll give
them the 350 billion in arms but we're
not going to impose our values on them
because it just wouldn't be polite and
we're talking about a country in Saudi
Arabia that still beheads people we have
a story two weeks ago about maybe there
would be somewhat progressive in terms
of allowing women to drive not having
male Guardians anymore right and yet
this is one of our top two allies in the
Middle East and on top of that with
Trump there's always a double standard
the Trump campaign Trump during his
campaign complained about how Obama
Hillary and Democrats were selling
weapons to Saudi Arabia and obviously
the exact same thing that's not really
news America has sold weapon to the
Saudis for ages the news is that Trump
was so against it when Obama did it but
now it's something that he has
absolutely no problem with many people
talking about this with us on our reddit
discussion forum check it out at david
pakman.com slash read it